[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
ich war mal wieder auf tour und zwar war
ich in berlin auf der ifa die ifa das
ist die internationale funkausstellung
und sie findet jedes jahr in berlin
statt und ist eine der größten industrie
messen weltweit und dort haben
hersteller einfach die möglichkeit ihre
produkte vorzustellen und wirklich ganz
ganz breites publikum auch anzuziehen
ich bin nicht zum ersten mal auf der ifa
sondern schon das dritte jahr dort und
immer wieder bin ich begeistert was es
für neue produkte geht was es für
innovationen gibt und ich mache
traditionell natürlich immer zuerst
einmal meinen rundgang und natürlich war
ich auch dieses jahr wieder einen tag an
einem stand ich war dieses mal am stand
von bosch und es war wirklich richtig
genial also ein ganz ganz toller stand
und ich habe da einen tag lang koch und
back shows gemacht habe man die
zuschauer getroffen und es war wirklich
super schön ich zeige euch jetzt aber
erst mal ein paar impressionen von der
ifa vielleicht findet er aber auch die
ein oder anderen neuen produkte ein paar
neuheiten 1 fertig verraten es war
wirklich wieder super lustig auf der
messe wir haben wir das sehr viel
zusammen erlebt motor mit dabei haben
wir dann ein bisschen was angestellt
mein team war mit dabei und hat mich
natürlich mit der kamera begleitet und
wir sind in berlin angekommen und sind
sofort auf die messe gestimmt um direkt
zu schauen was es so neues gibt unsere
tour startet in halle 3 er habe ich muss
dazu sagen heute morgen hat er murat
mich ziemlich gestresst und ich musste
selbst frische aus dem hotelzimmer raus
ich habe meine haare jetzt zwar gut
gefüllt aber bin ein bisschen
unzufrieden glätteisen konnte ich leider
nicht mehr benutzen
es war einfach keine zeit jetzt habe ich
hier direkt einen stand entdeckt bei
vermisst hier glaube ich dass mir da
fordern nämlich mal ganz schön die haare
glätten
hier gibt es aber ein fabia das heißt
jetzt einfach ein bisschen eintritt
die ifa da könnt ihr euch sogar hier
noch die haare stylen lassen
gerade ich gehe mal die haare glätten
lassen okay dass ich mal kurz verraten
was es für innovationen neuheiten gibt
und dann was mir die haare machen und
erkläre ich nebenher die produkte
also annikas gerade zeit für mich und
wir probleme zu drei geräte aus und es
waren wir einmal einen glocken gerät wie
nennt man das eigentlich professionell
ein auto kann
das besondere an der produktreihe ist
dass sie karten beinhalten das heißt die
keramikplatten die sind angereichert mit
piraten und mit mandelöl das heißt die
haare werden nicht nur geteilt sondern
gleichzeitig auch gepflegt also beim
auto köln nimmt man eine ganz dünne
strähnen und legte dann hinein drückt
auf den knopf und dann werden sie es
nicht mehr dreht dann ist es soweit dann
öffne zeitschaltuhr unter und die gibt
es mit 15 und 15 sekunden seinen langen
haaren muss man natürlich 15 sekunden
wählen und dann je nachdem was man haben
möchte locken oder auch nur wellen kann
man das ganze euro-schirms teilen
[Musik]
jetzt könnte ich mir gerade meine haare
dennoch ich möchte ich heute nicht
rumlaufen sondern lieber mit glatten
haaren und bei den preisen ist das
besondere
damit die feuchtigkeit in meinen haaren
und zwar acht mal in der sekunde
das heißt hier oben hat man ja mehr
feuchtigkeit im haar die haarspitzen sie
manchmal eher trockener und es heißt
hier oben habe ich mehr hitze und weiter
unten geht an die hitze runter und er
reguliert es wirklich sekundenschnell so
werden die haare nicht noch ist ein
sondern auch schön gepflegt
[Musik]
das bin ich das teilt jetzt kann es
weitergehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und letztes jahr hier auf der ifa und
habe mir zum beispiel auch produkte
ausgesucht die eben später in mein
zukünftiges haus rein fahren braucht
jetzt gerade hier im hintergrund mit
einem normalen handstaubsauger aber ich
bin jetzt hier weil das hämatom und die
haben nicht nur handstaubsauger sondern
auch zentral staubsauger anlagen
hier seht ihr zum beispiel eine zentrale
staubsauger anlage als grafik und sowas
werden wir auch später in unser
zukünftiges haus bekommen das heißt was
ist erst wie es funktioniert und wie es
eingebaut wird seht ihr bald in meinen
videos
neben mir steht der thomas der
geschäftsführer der firma thoma und die
stellen ja die produkte in deutschland
her oder wir sind eigentlich ein typisch
deutsches mittelständisches unternehmen
heute in der vierten generation
das heißt mein großvater hat das
unternehmen gegründet die produkte
werden in neuenkirchen im siegerland
eigentlich im herzen deutschlands nicht
nur produziert sondern auch entwickelt
designt und auch er gesteht ich glaube
ich hab mich richtig entschieden oder
wahl mit der central staub förderanlage
darauf gesagt ich habe das produkt
selber im eigenen haus gesprengt haben
ich glaube wenn man es nicht mehr missen
wollen
das ist okay also da freue ich mich
jetzt schon ganz ganz besonders
kraftstoff das haus wird bald fertig
sind kann ich gleich anfangen zu sorgen
da muss es dem rat nicht mehr machen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
versuchen wir unser glück
nicht mal mehr
die gleichen
mein gott
[Musik]
danke
ich habe es gewonnen einem magneten für
den kühlschrank
[Musik]
passt der kleine roboter hier
herunterladen man kann mit alexa
sprechenden einkaufen und jammert die
hände fuchstanz erzählt haben den pott
kaffee einstudiert
[Musik]
ein leckeres musik von angie danke
weitergeht
murat moralischen das schon wieder
hinten
[Musik]
nein
ich ruhe mich kurz aus brauchst den
kosten kommen raus
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hi
[Musik]
meine frau
also nicht erst von dem moment als wir
uns kennengelernt und später auch
gestreckt und der gefällt mir
[Musik]
ich hab die banane misst du dir
geschossen
nein
ist das was
ich weiß es nicht
so schlecht darin freitag benannt
liga playoffs engagiert hat
wir haben
wo hat das ist selbst stehen bereits auf
der couch twitter mein armes gibt's doch
nicht
murat springsport zurück das gibt's doch
nicht überall wo wir sind in der einfach
die einhörner mit
monaten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sowas in der küche kenia oder 360 ° c
linie
und er kann von jedem blickwinkel auf
fragt einfach über die schulter einen
behinderten schulter egal wie und
außerdem sieht man dann den murat in der
region
hier bin ich jetzt in der vorschlägen 2
ihr habt wahrscheinlich mitbekommen dass
vor kurzem eine herdplatte um ein
backofen entgehen
das übrigens in brand und damit die
geräte ausgetauscht und ich habe mir
noch vom küchenstudio bosch geräte
ausgesucht die habe ich jetzt auch schon
mehrere monate getestet aber natürlich
weiß ich noch nicht alles über die
geräte hier am stand hat man wirklich
alles rund um den kompletten haushalt
der ganze haushalt ist hier abgedeckt
und ich muss sagen dass stand ist
wirklich einer der schönsten und vor
allem einer der größten stände
er hat fünf verschiedene bereiche und
wird starten jetzt direkt hier hinter
mir mit dem bereits teil des areals sind
erste kühlschrank der die farbe wechseln
kann
wahrscheinlich kennt ihr das was ihr
euch mal den kühlschrank aussucht was
muss tagen im kühlschrank in dem coolen
farben habe ich eigentlich fragt auch
noch nie gesehen aber erkennen dass
wahrscheinlich erst ein kühlschrank
findet ihn jetzt toll aber nächstes jahr
ist schon wieder auf
ihr habt jetzt die möglichkeit mit dem
vario style einfach mit kühlschrank
front auszusuchen gemeinsam mit dem
kühlschrank natürlich und dann zum
beispiel irgendwann einfach die farbe zu
wechseln was man machen kann farben
verschiedenen kombinieren und so weiter
und das ganze ist so einfach dass all
das kann auch ich machen hier einfach
wegnehmen und dann kann man die farbe
wechseln und dann ganz einfach wieder
anhängen und zwar funktioniert das ganze
durch einen magneten
jetzt war vor einem monat mit freude der
willkommenen gelb-schwarzen kühlschrank
das feuer das sich in cannes mit den
jungs fußball gucken
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ihr seht schon in diesem bereich geht
alles und entstanden und zwar uns
entspannte wochen bricht sensor
unterstützung und da schauen wir uns
hinten mal die ganzen verrückten den
perfect sense habe ich auch zu hause in
meinem backofen und haben auch schon
ausprobiert und es wirklich super und
zwang ich da ganz neue kuchenrezepte
oder allgemein kuchenrezepte
ausprobieren kann den guten in den ofen
schieben und der ofen erkennt dann
einfach durch den bugs in savannah
perfekte gar punkt erreicht ist dass der
kuchen wird nicht matschig er ist noch
nicht fertig das passiert nicht mehr
sondern der kugel deswegen perfekt
gebacken ohne dass es trocken wird
einmal im backofen habe ich auch die
perfekt los funktion und zwar ist das
thermometer integriert mit dabei das
habe ich auch schon beim einem kebab
rezept zum beispiel ausprobiert und zwar
so den perfekten garten von fleisch
dadurch habe ich natürlich noch mal eine
liebeserklärung vom hochrad bekommen
denn dadurch liegt damit noch ein
stückchen mehr weil es vielleicht
wirklich immer super perfekt aus dem
backofen kommen
was ist denn das für abend im topf das
hier ist eine perfekte sensor und zwar
mit dem einfach nichts mehr über das
leid ich kann die temperatur eben nicht
kann zum beispiel milch kochen ohne dass
er über koch ich kann nur die wasser
kochen will ohne dass in silber oder ich
kann auch passieren ohne dass wir da
sind wir in einem land zu heiß wird den
sensor habe ich zu hause auch da liegt
allerdings bei mir in der schublade
denn ich wollte denn hier auf der ifa
einfach mal ausprobiert und es werde ich
später auch noch mal
e mails einfach fällt mit integriertem
dienst abgezogen
es war mir in der küche im moment so
dass ich nicht uns zu glauben an der
decke habe die funktioniert aber auch
nur weil ich keine zu hohen decken habe
in unserer neuen küche später gleich das
ganze leider nicht mehr dennoch will
einfach die decke viel viel höher ist
das einzig brauchen wir
dunstabzugshauben die tiefer hängt aber
natürlich das sichtfeld bei mir stören
durch die kamera natürlich und ich bin
auch so ein teppich stoßen wir immer mal
gerne den kopf sowie bei meiner mama
gerade in der kirche
deswegen wird bei mir wahrscheinlich die
herdplatte einziehen mit integriertem
dunstabzug und zwar ist unser zug da wo
er wirklich auch gebraucht wird also da
wo die töpfe sind
das ganze ist wirklich so markant zu
vereinen aus nehmen auch reinigen das
ganze ist für maschinen geeignet und
funktioniert echt zu haben
und vor allem ist es mit klaus und ich
habe da noch die möglichkeit hätte zum
beispiel hinter mir kurz zu lagern
jetzt sind wir hier im wäscheraum also
in der wäschekammer sozusagen und hier
gehts richtig tolle neuheit und den muss
sagen ich bin jetzt schon sehr
begeistert und zwar haben wir einen
scanner hast du ein scanner in einem
waschraum oder in einem haushalt
allgemein ab und zwar könnt ihr damit
kleidung scannen aber nicht nur kleidung
sondern auch lebensmittel
ich zeige euch jetzt erst mal hier im
wäscheraum mit der kleidung später gehen
wir noch in der küche da wird uns die
alex dem trainer erklären und zwar
hatten wir vor kurzem das szenario ich
habe mir ein richtig cooles kleid
gekauft das war aus wildleder extra in
seiner apotheke kaufen im morast mich so
darauf gefreut hat es einmal an und was
passiert eigentlich sollte das kleid zur
reinigung aber der moral ist mein bruder
ehemann da gerne mal auf die wäsche
macht hat das kleid bei 60 grad
gewaschen 1100 umdrehungen und es bleibt
dann noch in einem trockner gesteckt
jetzt habe ich kein kleid mehr ist passt
ungefähr
ja ich glaube der baby born von samira
und das ganze hätten wir verhindern
können indem der mode entsteht markt
hätte oder älter wird diesem scanner
genommen und zwar kaum mit dem scanner
kleidung analysieren
ich kann raus bekommen was für ein stoff
ist es denn wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel
das etikett schon weggeschnitten
entweder kann ich nur die kleidung
analysieren ich kann sagen ich möchte
sie waschen
ich möchte sie trocknen im trockner zum
beispiel oder ich möchte einen trick
entfernen
denn oft ist es bei uns zum beispiel
auch so eller komm nach hause mit ihrer
großen schwester
und sie haben tausende flecken auf ihren
t shirt und ich weiß gar nicht was ist
denn mit dem scanner habe ich dann die
möglichkeit sogar die flecken
organisieren
ich habe keine ahnung wie das ganze
funktioniert ich bin einfach nur mega
begeistert ich zeige euch zu sagen
also ich würde mal sagen da ich keine
flecken auf meinem karohemd habe machen
jetzt einfach mal weg los das heißt ich
gehe es hier auf die funktion drückt
drauf jetzt muss ich erstmal haben einen
karohemd scannen analysiert gerade was
ist im stoff
kochen also baumwolle das stimmt
dann drücke ich da drauf und will jetzt
aus was es denn für ein kleidungsstück
sei diese bluse eine hose und so weiter
beim nächstes jetzt shirt und bluse und
jetzt steht hier das ideale
waschprogramm und zwar 40 grad 800
umdrehungen und jetzt kann ich wenn ich
natürlich die partner der waschmaschine
dazu besitze kann ich das ganze von dem
scanner direkt an die waschmaschine
senden muss im prinzip die waschmaschine
nicht mehr per hand einstellen
das heißt nicht nur noch auf ok
und hier auf dem bildschirm der
waschmaschine ändert sich sozusagen das
programm
das heißt so spart man sich doch sind
berater denn es gibt keinen streit mehr
darüber ob die wäsche gewaschen hat oder
nicht
morath wir wollen einen wäsche scanner
und den kannst du nämlich auch in der
küche benutzen ich glaube ich den wind
einfach mal mit und geht zum alex hilfer
der erklärt mir jetzt nämlich dem
scanner für lebensmittel ich muss darum
laufen
alle dax bei dir steht sogar dein name
0,4 alexa traum für alle schon auf dem
strich tradition
[Musik]
samira und ich hatte etwas mitgebracht
einen aspekt übrigen kann ich schon ich
glaube ich muss dir zu ich habe gerade
gesagt dass ich der perfekte partner
sozusagen weil der buch hat jetzt meine
wäsche nicht mehr falsch machen kann und
wir dadurch keine ehekrise mehr bekommen
ist recht so ein männerproblem ich habe
in den letzten jahren auch schon so
viele sachen kaputt gemacht wie
waschmaschinen trockner mit dem degen
ist wahrscheinlich der titel der schau
ist jedoch bei lebensmitteln haben
zum beispiel könnte man fest wie viel
wasser gehalt ist hat also basiert
qualitätscheck die beim hackfleisch wie
es geht sagt drin falschen prozent
schweinefleisch ist ja interessant sind
sie einen vergleich stück einfach aus
gründen damit es später nicht
wegschmeißen müssen wir hatten richtig
angst habe ich den ganzen tag
geschlossen
dabei kommen frische check machen wie du
hast dich ja genial da kann ich ja
praktisch sonst gerne mit zum nächsten
dönerladen nehmen und mir schon spielst
du schon mal ganz genau steckt da
wirklich nur rind und lamm drin oder
steckt noch mehr mädchen manchmal nur so
hast du wirst der nächste hinten auf
du wirst das nächste boehner spiels
tester mit diesem scanner kanzlerin
die meisten leute ich hab echt anfühlen
und spießte länger hinhalten und sagen
hey hast schweinen drin oder und bin
nicht oder wahnsinn ja ich könnte auch
ein bruder hinhalten müssten heißen ist
schon okay meine weiter weg ok
frische aktiviert ist es schon weitere
lebensmittel bewusst ernährung ist ja
mit diesen themen die leute wollen
wissen was ist mir im dienst mittendrin
hier können hallenmeisterin anschaulich
die kalorien hatte es wie viele
residenten und beim obst ganz klar ist
frei er soll sich noch ein paar tage
stehen lassen ok also das muss ich sagen
also das geld für mich echte innovation
vor allem fertig entwickelt also
erklärung jedoch nicht
frisches lang so teuer also nicht auf
dem markt sondern hier wie vor zum
auschecken also schon am karohemd
getestet und es hat super funktioniert
perfekt drauf machen du kannst es ist
ihm zu nadal beim rat finden wir
vielleicht gleich blicken die erholung
da kann man die analysieren so aber alex
auf der ifa ist dieses jahr
sprachsteuerung glaube ich ein ganz ganz
großes thema
jeder möchte sprachstörungen keiner will
mehr schreiben die kids schicken wir
alle auch nur noch sprachnotizen keine
sowohl das ist das stichwort hier vorne
schon alex was hat man hier das jüngste
amazon eco und in dem eco das
lautsprecher mit einem mikrofon heißt
alex h
der wollte wechselte denn wir haben eine
schwester rexer und dies ganz klug und
ist eine sprachassistentin jetzt sich
zum backofen hingegen um mich anzumachen
du kannst es über den wechsel steuern
erklärte tagen das heißt ich kann einmal
die backöfen und geräte über meine app
steuern die ich habe und ein mal eben
auch per sprachsteuerung über alexander
organischen also alexandra lexer okay
geben dass mit dem rufen alexa
start home connect offen ok welche werte
möchtest du einstellen
sagel assistieren vorsichtig anmerken
soll
alexa staatsreform connect offenbar 180
grad ober und unterhitze 4 20 minuten
der film startet mit ober unterhitze bei
180 karten 20 minuten super hat geklappt
wolle
der ofen ist man kann sich auch wieder
ausscheiden wie das ok weil ich habe
jetzt keinen kuchen gebacken das heißt
wir wollen keine energie verschlüsse die
müsse differenziert immer das machen wir
dann morgen und das linke stark unter
den planungen für den kuchen deswegen
schalten nur wieder aus alexa sagen
connect offen das r stoppen soll
wie soll ich den ofen ausschalten ja ja
der ofen wurde ausgeschaltet weil wir
frauen den barocken heute eher nicht
denn es gibt erst morgen kuchen super
alex cejka lisa alex hat mich sehr
gefreut
wir sehen uns am morgen wieder
angespannt und kuchen was gibt's
verschiedene muffin kuchen hefezopf und
so weiter ich muss mir jetzt ganz
schnell verabschieden ich sehe die küche
da hinten die räume schon abend nicht ob
ich noch was zu essen kriege und dann
geht's weiter
[Musik]
was eigentlich ja heute auch die zutaten
waren sind spontan in die küche ein
bisschen vielleicht kann ich auch schon
das rezept für morgen herr ausprobieren
das habe ich nach dem urlaub mitgebracht
und meine haare zu machen
ach gott ach gott da ist ja cool
darf ich denn mit lehrern ist es darauf
gesprüht oder drauf gemalt
er hat es gemacht habe ich ja genau das
strichmännchen vor
danke
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die
das ist schon mal und dann machen wir
auch die kartoffel
[Musik]
und es soll ja
weiter
ja ich bin den ganzen tag da
vielleicht doch schon mal wieder so was
ich kaufe aber wieder so weit dann auch
mal
schade ich hätte gerne etwas von meinem
leben aber der
es gab käsekuchen wir haben wir haben
wir hier mit risikogeschäften habe ich
so viel zeit vertrödelt jetzt sind die
kirche natürlich schon fertig stellte
marius und da hat seine kochschürze aus
mario ich hab dich verpasst
ja stimmt ja ich habe nichts mehr zu
essen geht trägt bis zum morgen oder
übermorgen ja da kriegst du was von mir
passt und wer die perfekte morgen ja was
ich hier am stand von bosch richtig cool
fand zumindest gibt innovationen auf der
ifa wirklich an jedem stand
hier finde ich es ganz gut dass es
wirkliche innovationen gibt die sich
auch jeder leisten kann
das heißt ein backofen hier gibt es
wirklich in jeder klasse meiner mama
bekommt einen ich bekomme einen und man
kann sich das auch wirklich super
leisten ich mache es für heute
feierabend morath ich hab hunger wir
müssen was essen wir haben die koch show
verpasst
und ja dann geht es morgen weiter und
morgen geht es von uns die koch und back
show und ich bin jetzt schon gespannt
werden wir alles dabei was man eben
später weil ihr schaut euch später
weiter
jetzt müssen wir noch kurz einkaufen
gehen also die basis sachen hat bosch
für mich gesorgt mail und so weiter
ich fahre ich noch ein paar sachen auf
dem türkischen markt deswegen sind wir
bei eur wieder so wie letztes jahr und
gucken jetzt einfach mal ob ich alles
finden aber ich gehe natürlich davon aus
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
dass erdbeeren 34
habt ihr auch spitz paprika
[Musik]
stimmt jetzt in krabat von sirup den
brauche ich morgen zum abschmecken und
was ganz wichtig dass in der
zutatenliste wirklich nur granatapfel
konzentrat steht bei vielen ist nämlich
auch zucker noch mit dabei und es ist
wirklich die pure frucht die teure die
süße und damit kann man richtig salat
und andere gerichte wunderbar abrunden
der murat möchte immer das sind wir auf
messen sind dass er dann auch geschenke
für die zuschauer mitbringen
damals überlegt wir verteilen morgen
einfach zu tun moritz lieblingsmarke lag
sondern die in scheiben nehmen und wie
viel soll
so kommen noch ein paar mehr moral seine
das schwäbische reiz kommt die panische
großzügigkeit
ich glaube es reicht dass ich geh zur
kasse und bezahle und dann sehen wir uns
morgen auf der messe wieder verbal so
war simonas teenager herbst zugänglich
sind
guten morgen nach der messe ist
natürlich vor der messe heute ist tag 2
heute ist meine koch show der große tag
und bevor jetzt natürlich über ge zur
kochshow werde ich wie jeden morgen ein
kaffeetrinken kommen wo bekommt man den
besten kaffee nicht bei den italienern
deswegen bin ich jetzt hier weiter long
und schau mal ob david 33 ist denn ich
hab gehört der victor macht den besten
kaffee
hellwig teils erfreuliche auch ich würde
gerne auf italienisch sagen eine kaputte
oder 81 macchiato bitte aber ich kann
gern italienisch sehr gut was hast du
für mich es geht aber auch um das
dringend dringend einen latte macchiato
ist natürlich wieder hast du gerne haben
das mache ich die mit unseren neuen
prima donna clara und das schöne an
diesem neuen projekt produkt ist dass
wir hier ein gerät haben was er so
einfach zu bedienen ist und deswegen
darfst du denn auch selbst zubereiten
würde ich war gerne laufen erklärte
wolltest du einfach traurig genau so ein
fan ist also wir haben hier das ist das
einfach an dem gerät sechs
direktwahltasten wo man sehr sehr simpel
und einfach seine standard getränke
zubereiten kann
selbst wenn es morgens bühne ist kann
man das ohne weiteres machen
sie kann aber mehr sechs gesamt 15
spezialitäten machen und du siehst ja
hier den latte macchiato werde jetzt
schön automatisch aufgefordert unsere
platte klimasystem
wir haben richtig schön schauen wir
nicht auskommen meint er denn besser
kenne ich ja schon hier habe ich auch zu
hause und ich wäre der perfekte mix
schauen immer richtig nicht nur dass ich
für meine mama war die maschine besser
weil sie eben wie das auf die symbole
einfach drücken kann
ja das ist richtig das muss man ja auch
einen touch das ist für uns ganz
praktisch und übers handy ja und für die
mama wäre das echt eine ganz tolle
geschichte
das ist ja oft so also meine mutter ist
da nicht anders also sie braucht und
cappuccino und kanada und direkt hier
ist es direkt offen liegen sehr simpel
einfach zu bedienen das ganze
das ist also das schöne daran und wie
dein gerät hier auch ist das ganze hier
auch bei der primadonna glas mit einer
etwa wenn man das möchte
da kann man die ganzen denke hier
abrufen die das geht zubereiten kann man
kann hier alles einstellen
wo also die stark soldaten sein warum so
weiter
das kann man alles bedeuten wenn man das
möchte
und für mich ist gerade keiner bei aber
ich würde das gerne für die schon bin
ich schön mega hammer oder perfect
kaffee experte weiter so und hier sind
wir unserer marke braun und auch hier
ein paar neuheiten für dieses jahr
zeigen beim thema kaffee wo wir gerade
waren natürlich auch kaffee bohnen und
falls man nicht den vollautomaten hat
sondern vielleicht ein filter maschine
oder im siebträger für das presse haben
wir jetzt beim mq 9 eine neue kräuter
gewürze mit der man aber auch
kaffeebohnen machen könnte und das ist
nicht mal ganz kurz so sehr einfach und
schnell gemacht
deckel drauf je nachdem die partie nicht
sein soll einfach etwas länger laufen
lassen da etwas kürzer und schon ist
das ist dabei in dem film einsatz mit
der rechtlich soll die frische ja und
ich glaube im café ist eine ganz
schwierige doch da nicht zu heiß wäre ja
genau weil wenn es zu lange dauert mit
dem café mahnt dazu heißt und dania
verbrennt der rüstet ja und das soll
nicht passieren und schon genug aber das
ist ein kurzer zeit erledigt ist und wie
auch gesagt dass ich eine kräuter
gefühlsmäßig habe ich ein paar tagen
gemacht hat die eigenen dinge werden
möchte
das ist ja wie beim kaffee das gleiche
fragt man sich vielleicht wofür brauche
ich das ja wenn kaffee frisch gemahlen
wird oder anderswo wenn es eine bohne
ist dann bleibt das aroma viel länger
lang und genau so ist es ja hier auch
unser trend geht ganz klar dass du doch
die leute immer mehr auch eigene gehört
so ein altes buch die er nicht erzählen
die lampen gewürzmischung machen
auf strecken je nachdem wie vor nichts
haben
man könnte auch pulsen in dem eine kuh
ist ein bisschen größer sind je nachdem
wie feines sein soll kann ich länger
laufen dass man gekürzt und habe ich
echt regel kinder nicht richtig durch
und super eigene geht es mir schon
wichtig korrigieren hat drei kinder
das habe ich das okay das große themen
sind das wusste ich natürlich nicht
besser aber bei murat habe ich solche
probleme
von daher kindersicherung ist ganz gut
bei ihm wie ich glaube diese mieter kann
auch damit umgehen von mir welches die
kinder sind inzwischen so was habe ich
noch schönes bauen wir haben einen neuen
standmixer aber das thema ist mutig ist
ja echt ein riesen trennten geworden zum
einen mit dem großen mit besser wenn man
für die ganze family was machen möchte
wenn man aber sagt nehen nur für mich
alleine haben wir auch zwei sowie timo
becker mit dabei magst du probieren ja
es wird einfach oben drauf gesteckt
ich denke das gerät einschalten
[Musik]
fertig fertig ist das nur sehen und dann
abschrauben das messer dann ist dieser
deckel mitarbeiter darauf machen kann
so hat somit nehmen die auto zur arbeit
es ist einfach schön morath meter
daneben ist aber der war schon fünf mal
da und es kann dieses völlig okay kam
dann nämlich von johann und arbeitet mit
da ich glaub ich verabschiede mich von
der ob jetzt sowohl maßgeblich dazu
kaffee wie geht es dir
ich bin sehr zufrieden und ja aber geht
es bei euch auch und ja ja wir sind
natürlich wie immer hier bei canon und
sie läuten das produkt ja die puppen
schmackhaft zu machen und ansonsten auf
die deutlich zu sehen genau und nicht so
ist noch da bist so schön
ich bin nicht so lange da heute leiter
ja heute auch kochshow ein bisschen habe
mir gedacht komm ich vorbei
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt werden wir beide aus einer
schüssel essen wie sonst in streit
also ich find's super lecker und sieht
auch superschön das ganze ken duken
schiff ja das leben kann so einfach sein
beim gucken wer soll das jetzt hier kurz
noch ab dann gehe ich rüber bereite mich
für die koch show sehen wir uns wieder
genau wie bedanken
[Musik]
aber jetzt bin ich bereit für die letzte
kochshow heute ich hab heute schon zwei
hinter mir
und zwar habe ich heute mittag bereits
um 11 uhr mit koch schaut macht- und da
habe ich mit murat und dem gas zusammen
in der küche gestanden
wir haben chart maccabi gemacht also
nichts leckeres fleisch gericht ein
rezept man sich aus der türkei
mitgebracht habe und was man auch schon
beiden neuen kochbuch finden wird und
ansonsten ein paar süße sachen herzhafte
sachen ich habe bulgur salat gemacht und
die zuschauer durften natürlich
probieren wir haben wir fragen gestellt
dich auch antwortet habe jetzt bin ich
bei der letzten kochshow
da gehen wir jetzt auch gleich nach
vorne in die küche um eine schürze habe
ich bereits jetzt gibt noch browning
hinweg reden ja was mache ich dann noch
linsen so viel zum abschluss und hefe
schnecken also zimtschnecken und dann
ist es zu ende und ja ich bin mal
gespannt darauf wie ist das feedback
sein wird also kommt man ja heute letzte
kochshow ich bin eigentlich grad warm
geworden also ich könnte eigentlich ist
gerade so weiter machen
die nächsten tage aber ich nicht morgen
früh leider schon wieder nach hause
kassen
ich werde dich wieder verlassen
ja das mache mache ich ja also was
erwartet euch hier
ich habe brownies vorbereitet zu eurem
glück waren sie vorhin nicht fertig und
wir konnten sie vorhin nicht rausgeben
jetzt könnt ihr sie probieren gleich
mache ich himbeereis dazu und schmecken
aber schon vorbereitet eine linsensuppe
gibt's gleich zum abschluss
[Musik]
das waren jetzt impressionen von unseren
zwei tagen auf der ifa
ich muss natürlich dazu sagen zwei tage
eva es viel zu wenig also man kann da
wirklich eine komplette woche verbringen
und hat immer noch nicht alles gesehen
ich habe versucht aus allen bereichen so
ein bisschen was anzuschauen
ein bisschen rein zu schnuppern wir
haben fernsehgeräte gesehen ich habe mit
murat an der nintendo gespielt es war
nintendo geld war kein playstation okay
ich kenne mich da nicht so gut aus aber
es mal an den tempo hat auch sehr viel
spaß gemacht wir haben stoff vorgesehen
stoff folge anlage und so weiter und ich
denke dass für jeden wirklich auch was
dabei war was ich noch dazu sagen möchte
technische innovationen sind wirklich
super genial also ich finde was man
heutzutage mit der technik alles machen
kann ist wirklich sehr toll
es gibt natürlich innovationen die
braucht kein mensch andere brauchen es
vielleicht was für mich sinnvoll ist in
innovationen in der küche vor allem also
klar kann man auch mit einem ganz
normalen herd mit einem normalen
backofen mit ober unterhitze die besten
gerichte zaubern und auch sex und kochen
aber dennoch es ist sehr sinnvoll zum
beispiel der herzlaker zu haben die die
temperatur steuern kann
ich spare mir so zum beispiel eine
friteuse weil ich jetzt auf meinem herz
die temperatur ist so einstellen kann
dass man fett also meant frittierfett
einfach nicht überhitzt dass die
pfannkuchen nicht verbrennen das gargut
nicht zu sehr über kocht von daher ist
es wirklich sehr sinnvoll die milch
kocht übrigens auch nicht mehr über das
kann der murat es mittlerweile auch und
es brennt natürlich auch nichts mehr an
aber natürlich muss jeder einfach für
sich selber entscheiden welche
innovationen für ihn oder für sie
einfach am sinnvollsten sind was mich
wieder sehr gefreut hat war einfach mein
zuschauer tag das heißt amboss stand war
es wirklich sehr schön
ich hatte drei koch und back show und
ich glaube bei der zuschauer war noch
alles sehr begeistert und ich muss auch
echter zu sagen wir haben von allen
seiten lob bekommen dass ich so tolle
zuschauer habe und das möchte ich
natürlich auch gerne an euch zurück
geben ihr seid einfach so lieb und so
geduldig und ich glaube es ist aber
einfach so das gesamtpaket was immer
zwischen uns auch natürlich stimmt und
deswegen freue ich mich immer sehr auf
messe zu gehen und euch alle zu treffen
ich hoffe natürlich dass im nächsten
jahr das es dann genauso schön wird oder
vielleicht noch schöner was ich mir kaum
vorstellen kann
aber es war wirklich super genial auf
der messe habe ich wieder ganz ganz
leben menschen kennengelernt zum einen
die menschen die man vor der kamera und
auch in der küche nicht sieht das sind
nämlich die fleißigen
vor dem hintergrund die haben in der
küche wirklich die zutaten super
vorbereitet und auch beim servieren
immer ganz toll geholfen und da schicke
ich wirklich ein ganz ganz großes
dankeschön an das gesamte team
und dann habe ich in der küche noch die
küche kennen gelernt die kennt ihr
wahrscheinlich auch alle zum einen war
da roland trettl mit dabei ralf zacherl
mario kotaska und auch carsten dorhs der
kasten der hat mir sogar während meinen
kochen back schoss in der küche geholfen
und das war wirklich super lustig und
hat sehr viel spaß gemacht wir waren
dann abends noch mit allen essen und
zwar wirklich super witzig also die
gesamte messe war im prinzip für mich
ein toller ausflug hat viel spaß gemacht
war vor allem super lecker und wirklich
ganz ganz toll jetzt am wochenende wenig
wieder auf messe und zwar findet die
baden messe in freiburg statt und da
sind wir am samstag und am sonntag für
euch da wir werden schon
donnerstag/freitag natürlich mit dem
aufbau beschäftigt sein und ich werde
auch wieder ganz viele tolle sachen vor
backen und ja da freue ich mich auch
schon sehr drauf da gibt's dann auch an
jedem tag kochen back show ich werde
natürlich von morgens bis abends da sein
wir sind mit unserem kompletten stand da
also auch unser shop meine küche und
mein gesamtes team wird vor ort sein
auch da gibt es ein video dazu und wir
verlosen für diese messe auch wieder ein
paar freikarten
ich habe 50 freikarten zu verlosen und
wenn ihr die freikarten für die messe in
freiburg jetzt gewinnen möchtet dann
schreibt einfach eine e-mail
hier unten steht die e mail adresse und
wir schicken euch dann einfach eine e
mail zur b die karten gewonnen habt oder
nicht
ich freue mich jedenfalls schon sehr
drauf und bedanke mich fürs einschalten
und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]